one of the characteristic flaws of our
minds is to exaggerate how fragile we
might be to assume that life would be
impossible far earlier that is in fact
would be we imagined that we couldn't
live without a certain kind of income or
status or health that it would be a
disaster not to have a certain kind of
relationship house or job this natural
tendency of the mind is constantly
stoked by life in commercial society
which adds to our sense of the number of
things that must be considered
necessities rather than luxuries this
kind of society goes to extraordinary
lengths to get us to feel that we really
do need to go skiing once a year to have
heated car seats to fly in business
class to own the same kind of watch as a
famous conductor and have a jumbo sized
fridge and lay claim to lots of friends
perfectly muscular health and a loving
kind sex-filled relationship these
things would be nice but in fact our
core needs a much simpler than all this
we could in fact manage perfectly well
enough with a lot less not just around
possessions but across every aspect of
our lives it's not that we should want
to it's simply that we could we could
cope quite well with being rather poor
not very popular not having a very long
life and with living alone we could even
to put the extreme instance forward cope
with being dead it does happen
all the time but we forget our
resilience in a face of the risks we
face the cumulative effect of our
innocence is to make us
our lives become dominated by a fear of
losing with never getting things which
we could in fact do perfectly well
without the ancient Roman philosopher
Seneca had great success running what we
would now call a venture capital firm
he owned beautiful villas and
magnificent furniture but he made a
habit of regularly sleeping on the floor
of an outhouse and eating only stale
bread and drinking warm water he was
reminding himself that it wouldn't ever
be so bad to lose pretty much everything
so as to free himself from nagging
worries of catastrophe the realization
that he could be a penny gave him great
confidence he never worried so much for
that what might happen if a deal went
wrong because at the very worst he'd
only be back on the kitchen floor next
to the dog basket which was in the
scheme of things okay
Seneca was initiating an important move
by continually renewing our acquaintance
with our own resilience that is with our
ability to manage even if things go
badly or sacked a partner walking out a
scandal that destroys our social yards
an illness we can be braver because we
grasped that the dangers we face are
almost never as great as are skittish
imaginations tend to suggest in the
utopia our culture would stop
continuously presenting us with rags to
riches stories it would instead do
something far kinder and incidentally
far more conducive to the kind of
courageous entrepreneurial optimism that
our societies currently kinetically try
to foster our culture should be
continuously presenting us with charming
non tragic tales of riches-to-rags
stories stories in which people lost
money parks and social standing but
ended up coping really rather well with
their new lives we'd see them moving out
of the penthouse into a humble cottage
and having really rather a nice time
tending to a small flower bed and
discovering tinned food our culture
would not be recommending such scenarios
just lessening the grip upon us a
certain deep but misplaced fears that so
often hold us back
crying and succeeding we publish new
thought-provoking films every week be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your screen now